ciao a tutti
chi di voi ha un cellulare ok nel 1800
nel 1800 successo una cosa per costruire
una segheria uno scozzese un inglese
trovarono tre sassi però non erano sassi
erano pepite d'oro che si dissero tra di
loro non diciamolo a nessuno non deve
saperlo nessuno era il 1849 per i 150
anni successivi
quel periodo si chiama corsa all'oro
il segreto peggio tenuto della storia
umana folle oceaniche di persone si
muovevano alla volta di quella che oggi
chiamiamo california tutte quante con un
piano questo piano era scavare per terra
tutte con la stessa identica idea
diventare ricchi scavando per terra
tutte tranne una che guardò queste folle
oceaniche che da tutto il mondo
partivano alla volta della california
con quell idea di scavare e disse
diventerò ricco vendendo pale e picconi
e così feci si chiamava a masa leland
stanford che cosa fece stanford stanford
guardò dall'esterno fece un passo
laterale rispetto a tutto ciò che stava
accadendo in quell ecosistema e capi
com'è possibile che ogni volta che si
rinviene una pepita è la pepita più
grande mai trovata
chi è che ha interesse a far girare
questa voce
chi speculava della ferrovia chi
speculava sulla ferrovia investiva
tantissimo per far salire quello che
oggi chiameremmo live della della
ricerca dell'oro e muoveva un'economia
quello che fece stanford è stato fare un
passo laterale e hackerare il sistema
conoscete
questa università guarda caso si chiama
proprio università di stanford
ma non è un caso perché quando un
imprenditore riesce ad hackerare il
sistema crea un valore che va oltre le
generazioni la ricchezza che riesce a
trovare che riesce a creare non è la
ricchezza di chi fortuitamente ha
trovato un filone aurifero noi la
ricchezza di chi ha costruito ha trovato
un modo per mettere a sistema quello che
sta succedendo è diventato uno strumento
di quell ecosistema e se diventi uno
strumento di quello che un sistema 6
anche in grado di orientarlo di
cambiarlo
e adesso lo stesso posto quell'area
geografica dove prima si cercava loro
ancora adesso ci cerca loro ma in
maniera differente nel 1800 si cercava
loro
poi è venuto il periodo del tubo
catodico poi è venuto il periodo dei
test delle microonde dei circuiti
integrati dei personal computer di
internet e dei social media delle
intelligenze artificiali della blog
chain dell'alternativa energetica e le
energie alternative
quel posto dove vennero rinvenute nei
tre pepite si chiama silicon valley è
quello che ha creato stanford è stato un
sistema
un modo per guardare che cosa sta
succedendo e a tirarlo noi oggi stiamo
vivendo una stessa identica corsa
all'oro dobbiamo soltanto riuscire a
fare un passo laterale e capire che cosa
sta succedendo
se sei un imprenditore magari lavori
tutto il giorno magari fatichi magari
produci magari se un professionista e
hai studiato per il tuo valore
ti ritrovi in un ecosistema dove un
bambino o un ragazzo che devono latte
con il naso caricano quel video su
internet fanno più soldi di quanti ne
fai tu dopo una laurea una specialistica
dopo aver creato un'azienda ma quello
che devi fare non è pensare che allora
anch'io farò dei video con cui devo
latte dal naso perché non devi
arricchirti scavando per terra
tu devi semplicemente fare un passo
laterale capire in che ecosistema stiamo
vivendo
perché se lo capisci allora riesci a
capire in che modo dare valore al tuo
lavoro e hackerare quell'ago sistema noi
viviamo in un ecosistema in una società
chiamata società liquida il termine non
l'ho creato io non l'ho inventato io non
l'ha deciso uno studio di marketing è un
termine coniato dal filosofo zygmunt
bauman uno dei più accreditati filosofi
contemporanei i filosofi studiano
spiegano la realtà poi c'è una categoria
di persone che quando leggono le parole
dei filosofi quando capiscono la
spiegazione così ben fornita del
filosofo non gli basta saperla sono le
persone c'è una categoria che sono i
primi ad utilizzare quelle idee per
portare valore si chiamano imprenditori
il compito di un imprenditore questo è
compito di un imprenditore è risolvere
un problema che non è stato risolto
oppure risolvere meglio un problema già
risolto la tastiera con cui scrivete si
chiama tastiera qwerty
sapete perché perché le prime lettere
sono q wrt y
sapete perché perché un imprenditore ha
detto attenzione le macchine da scrivere
tendono ad avere i tasti che si
intrecciano si rompono si rovinano
quindi mettiamo i tasti che utilizziamo
meno frequentemente più distanti perché
quando fanno il percorso lungo i tasti
che si intrecciano è risolto un problema
risolvere un problema porta ricchezza
amazon ha risolto un problema ha reso
molto più semplice comprare le cose
certo tu risolve un problema e poi altri
che lo risolvevano prima devono correre
all'inseguimento
pensate quando è stata inventata la
lampadina
quante cererie hanno chiuso pensate
anche quanti elettricisti sono nati
il problema è che non è più tempo di
abituarsi perché se leggi bauman la
società liquida non è positiva e
negativa non è un'utopia una distopia
sapete l'aspetto peggiore
l'individuo non è più un individuo è
diventato un consumatore le persone non
sono più individui sono consumatori
siamo in un'economia di dati ed
algoritmi ve lo dimostro scendo dal
palco
parlo al telefono com'è andato il ted va
bene però adesso sono stanco voglio
prendermi una vacanza voglio andare alle
maldive
poi mi collego su un social mi spunta un
banner di una vacanza alle maldive chi
gliel'ha detto
nessuno di voi ha un cellulare
avete tutti uno smartphone c'è stato un
momento preciso nella vostra vita in cui
avete buttato via un cellulare e
perfettamente funzionante per prendere
uno smartphone
chi lo ha deciso non lo avete deciso voi
perché i mille cambiamenti che ci sono
nel mondo avvengono oggi sempre più
frequentemente all'interno di un cavallo
di [ __ ] chiamato tecnologia
se vuoi cambiare un'abitudine se vuoi
cambiare il modo in cui le persone fanno
qualcosa se vuoi stiller e un nuovo
comportamento non devi convincere non
devi spiegare devi dare uno strumento
vi ricordate il tuttocittà qualcuno lo
usa ancora no non ci hanno convinto di
non usarlo ci hanno semplicemente dato
uno strumento che fa molto meglio e se
ci mettiamo pensare a che cosa fa quello
strumento non ci sembra mica vero è
perché oggi la tecnologia
indistinguibile dalla magia tu oggi
parli al tuo telefonino con la tua voce
e l'intelligenza artificiale ed entra
quel telefono scompone in un algoritmo
101 quello che tu hai detto lo spara
nello spazio dove c'è un satellite che
fotografa dove sei e incrocia coi dati
su una mappa con i gps che tutti noi
portiamo in tasca per capire a che
velocità tutti quelli intorno a te si
muovono per capire
diresse quelli stanno andando in
bicicletta a piedi o in macchina perché
oltre alla mappa gli serve di tracciare
la velocità per poi ri sparare con le
informazioni all'interno della
intelligenza artificiale che porta in
tasca che le ri traduce in da un
algoritmo 101 in un segnale sonoro che
con voce femminile ti chiede percorso
più breve
ho percorso più veloce perché a seconda
della velocità con cui vanno tutti
quanti io so se c'è più o meno traffico
e questo avviene in secondi anzi se non
abbiano in secondi ci arrabbiamo nello
spazio il ritorno in secondi
certo che non usi più il tuttocittà io
lo dico per i giovani ragazzi noi una
volta avevamo questo libretto ed era
comodissimo perché tu dovevi andare in
un posto dove di sapere quale era quel
posto perché non è come adesso che dici
trovami il ristorante hicks non ho dovi
sapere dove fosse mandarli in fondo alla
pagina cercavi la via ri andavi sulla
pagina dove stava la via incrociavi
facevano specie battaglia navale tenere
il segno poi andavo in fondo prendevi
dove star li facevi un'altra battaglia
navale televisioni e queste due pagine
poi cercavi una pagina via l'altra di
trovarti la strada man mano che la
dovevi con chi era comodissimo voi
ridete era comodissimo
adesso però abbiamo magia abbiamo un
cavallo di [ __ ] chiamato tecnologia
certo qualcuno prima qualcuno dopo
questa è la legge di rogers la curva di
rogers qua ci sono gli adattatori
precoci anzi qua proprio alberti ci sono
i pionieri quelli che iniziano ad
utilizzare una nuova tecnologia quando
neanche quando ancora in versione beta
non è neppure funzionante non funziona
neanche bene ma a loro piace scoprire
cose nuove poi ci sono gli adattatori
precoci poi ci sono gli adattatori per
tardivi sapete l'amico che vi ho detto
io non userò mai il cellulare una
schiavitù
adesso ne ha tre lo ha scelto no ci sono
cambiamenti che tu non scegli non lo
puoi scegliere non sono cose che tu puoi
decidere dal 1980 al 2016
la nostra scrivania è svanita perché si
chiama società liquida perché le cose si
stanno liquefacendo le cose fisiche si
liquefanno ma nessuna di queste
una scelta che tu hai preso ti sta
accadendo intorno addosso dentro fuori e
non è più neanche aggiornato questo si
ferma al 2016 tutto il tuo ufficio
rimane un computer ma quando mai tutto
il mio ufficio il mio telefonino e
ancora non è vero
me ne sono accorto a bari due settimane
fa si apre la portiera del taxi vola via
al mio zaino con dentro il computer
tutti gli hard disk tutti i device
l'ipod il telefonino e
contemporaneamente perché a volte il
destino è sincronico passa uno di quei
pullman a due piani avete presente
quelli con i turisti e passa sopra il
mio zaino e io guardo questa parabola e
penso va beh ma tanto è tutto in cloud
c'è mica stanno lì dentro i dati i dati
sono ovunque mio computer e dovunque è
nel vostro computer se io voglio è
questa la società liquida e tutto non
conta più la fisicità quando ero piccolo
dovevi parlare veloce se parlavi da roma
a milano
io sono di roma da roma a milano tu
dovevi parlare veloce chi si ricorda
perché per le interurbane scattava più
velocemente costavano di più
prima quando ero piccolo oggi aprendo
uno schermo lo scritto in quattro e
parlo tra hong kong per londra da
palermo io gestisco le mie aziende così
video chiamo scambio documenti invio
video audio musiche quanto lo pago zero
perché perché il mondo è in mano oggi
non più agli investitori che speculano
sulla ferrovia sapete chi è che comanda
oggi il mondo le multinazionali
ci sono alcune multinazionali che hanno
un solo scopo nella vita rendere il più
facile possibile il più semplice
possibile perché fare soldi
grazie a loro perché se tu riesci a fare
soldi grazie a loro loro possono
continuare ad essere quelle
multinazionali che governano il mondo
perché sono sempre più importanti
per te e chi di voi ha un lavoro
chi di voi ha un'azienda chi di voi
lavora per un'azienda quindi tutti io
non sono qui a convincervi che voi
avrete un business liquido o che dovete
rendere liquida la vostra azienda perché
non è una scelta questo succederà
indipendentemente da voi adesso siamo in
quella finestra temporale in cui
possiamo decidere come facciamo ancora
in tempo adesso siamo nella curva
iniziale della legge di roger ma poi lo
faremo tutti non avete mai deciso di
passare da un cellulare uno smartphone è
un cavallo di [ __ ] la tecnologia ti
cambia le abitudini e non puoi mica
tornare a usare oggi un cellulare sei
tagliato fuori dal mondo
c'è un'altra cosa interessante per la
prima volta nella storia umana dobbiamo
risolvere dei problemi ma per la prima
volta nella storia umana
tutti questi cambiamenti a cui non
possiamo abituarci perché ci sono
tecnologie che cambiano completamente la
macchina quanto tempo ci ha messo un
secolo a diventare una tecnologia
utilizzata se io mi metto a pensare da
quando ero piccolo alle innovazioni
tecnologiche che hanno completamente
rivoluzionato le mie abitudini
quotidiane
il computer il personal computer il
cellulare internet il cellulare che si
collega ad internet
il cellulare di seconda terza quarta
generazione che si collega ad internet i
social network l'intelligenza
artificiale
un mese fa google ha annunciato che
hanno costruito il primo computer
quantico riesce a fare un'operazione da
24.000 anni in pochi minuti
e chissà quante ancora non abbiamo tempo
di adattarci e per la prima volta nella
storia i problemi che abbiamo devono
essere risolti da cinque aerei da cinque
generazioni differenti tradizionalisti
boomer generazione hicks millenni al
centenni als parlano degli stessi
problemi hanno lingue diverse
riferimenti diverse come se un uomo
della preistoria parlasse con uno del
basso medioevo che parla come uno del un
feudatario vi faccio un esempio
c'è qualcosa che ho letto su facebook
questa frase per questi due non ha avuto
senso per la maggior parte della loro
vita ha avuto senso da un certo punto in
poi ha senso per questo ha senso per
questo per questo non ha più senso
questi non sanno neanche cosa sia
facebook è vecchio e chi stanno su
facebook ma si parlano e devono
risolvere lo stesso problema risolve
riscaldamento globale problema semplice
no
lingue diverse dobbiamo vivere su questo
hilton ci ha messo a 93 anni ad avere
610 stanze in 88 paesi
airbnb ce l'ha messo e 44 anni 650 mila
stanze in 192 paesi
ora è vero una cosa loro fanno più utile
il fatturato più o meno uguale
però io preferisco avere l'utile di
airbnb tra quattro anni che quello di
hilton tra 93 perché tra 93 sarò molto
meno arzillo come fanno tolgono la
fisicità il tuo business quello che tu
sei bravo a fare quello per cui è
studiato non è più la partita non è più
il tool core business
non è più il tuo talento quella è
diventata una commodity acquistabile
amazon riesce a vendere le merci a un
prezzo più basso di chi le produce
perché la partita si gioca sulla
consegna sul rendere liquefatto il
negozio alibaba il più grande
distributore di merci non a magazzino
huber il più grande noleggiatore di auto
con conducente non ha un'auto
e questa la loro forza perché poi nei
paesi in cui gli dicono da oggi 6
illegale perfetto noi siamo huber
facciamo fu delivery prova a farlo se
tutti quanti i costi delle auto
cosa puoi fare oggi parti da un'idea la
devi validare validare vuol dire
lanciarla sul mercato e chiedere al
mercato di vali dartela chiedendo perché
l'intelligenza è diventata collettiva e
la somma di più intelligenze a airbnb è
nato air per affittare materassini
gonfiabili e stato il pubblico che gli
ha detto come doveva cambiare il
business
dopo di che crei un business liquido
cioè lanci un mvp un minimo prodotto
vendibile e poi in azienda liquida e poi
cresci sfruttate sfruttate queste
opportunità
mettiti al centro tutto il resto può
diventare liquido se avete un azienda
l'amministrazione reparto marketing
reparto vendite quello ricerca e
sviluppo può diventare tutto liquido
questo è il momento migliore il peggiore
per cercare un lavoro
il migliore per inventarsi un business
grazie
[Applauso]